california california california
the middle class famous tour is coming
to the left coast yeah guys april we're
gonna be in san francisco april fourth
we're gonna be in los angeles april six
we're gonna be in la jolla get your
tickets now it's a little bit of stand
up it's a little bit of ayg it's a whole
lot of fun do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage yep it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it if they grow up to be
classy or it's just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day down here at
auntie's basement forgot the right one
for the second time
just realize they come up on you quick
when you don't do the work my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the ceo of ru garbage he is
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with in the boardroom
kj kevin james ryan hey what's up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are true the
roof cooking and then obviously the
greatest website of all time patreon.com
turn you from a bozo to a homie real
[ __ ] quick over there patreon.com sir
check it out you get bonus episodes ayg
bonus episodes of hard feelings live
streams the whole nine yards also get
your [ __ ] tour tickets we're all over
the [ __ ] road california we just
announced get those [ __ ] tickets la
la jolla and san francisco get them now
callie's next let's [ __ ] go and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good we love him you
love him give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what up dudes hey t-bones
dude the vibe in here is like the crew
is back together after the heist
is a good old-fashioned hang on
i love wheel machine i love it i love it
reggie's dressed like a second story man
right now
she's about to hit mischief night he
came in in a stolen jacket by the way
baru gang we connected we're excited we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he is uh one of our best
pals started out together doing
fantastic jumps right now
he's an actor i did your credits before
but they've grown so much i'm gonna do
him again he's in the new screen
i did uh a season of uh michael che show
which you just did season two yep right
you're in it you're writing on it you're
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] doing it just
had a nice little part on [ __ ] abbott
elementary yep plenty of stuff in the
world loves [ __ ] doing some road
dates working the kids [ __ ] i don't
know about road dates
i've been to jersey
i'll be looking at your schedule like i
wonder if i go to that la one
i touched on them i came here when the
when scream came out or whatever i
thought yo man so [ __ ] cool
i'm like your [ __ ] movie star he's
like yeah but you're rich oh my god
good point
how's it going
just keep waiting you know it's late you
know patreon it's funny with the acting
stuff like you'd be so bitter by the
time we come out
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] two years later
the money's going like i'm watching abby
like look at this [ __ ] gotta go you
gotta go to the movies and pay for it
let me get [ __ ] paid for this goddamn
[ __ ] ladies and gentlemen mr reggie
conquest hey
yo it feels good to be here you don't
think i'll be don't be adding up y'all
patreon
you've got a couple of bucks now too
what are you talking about yeah but i'm
not really compared to where we came
compared to our stars
we're rich i love to see it it really it
excites me good stuff yeah i'm you know
we're still here do you think you you
think you've changed at all with a
little bit of money no do you like the
finer things a little bit i do i do like
to eat a little better like wow oh this
is big one what are you doing chucky
peanut butter
i'm going to whole foods i switched from
sprite to seven up
i like steak i'm a steak steak all right
uh i got into that during the pandemic
though that's when that uh
insecure money was hitting oh forgot
insecure yeah yeah so i got it i was
2020 was a good year
donny t i like like him or not
boy he can sign his name on his chest
but he catch checks steaks and i do like
eating out like a little bit you know
i'm getting into cocktail bars
just
drinking i want to go get a steak after
this really yeah i'm down you're growing
that tea we're going out to eat all
right i'm down you guys buying yeah of
course we wouldn't invite you if we yeah
i know you ain't got it on you i know as
soon as it's cut off we like peter
reggie
[Laughter]
where y'all going
i'm gonna go to gallagher's because i
was gonna hit bon chicken
i walked by i was like whoa hey it's
been there in a while
bond chicken what is it called bong
chong oh banchon bong chong yeah you
know there's no bunch
bonchon b-o-s-b-o yeah right poncho
korean fried chicken korean fried
chicken bon chan i think oh never
allowed to say this
[Laughter]
you never had it no it's bonchon it's
really good yeah
yeah yeah okay
chicken oh i was great on the subway
home
i see you're really living it up
yeah i can see you like the finer thing
that was great i take the express wait
wait wait so you guys are done with the
sub completely what do you mean the sub
the subway like catching it oh yeah i
haven't taken it in probably close to a
year see i was just having this that's
because of obesity that's that is
nothing to do with the money uh no no i
just can't do it anymore i was getting
frustrated because every time i decide
to catch a subway now people are running
oh you you why are you acting broke like
why are you yeah making a big deal about
sure and that that pisses me off because
like somebody like keanu reeves i
remember keanu reeves
still takes the subway he was all over
the subway people reposting the pictures
and celebrating them like oh he's so
down the earth and then he's already not
eating
i got one show and everybody's like why
are you catching the subway it's like i
still need i don't have that much money
yeah he wasn't eating pigeon wings on
the sixth street
don't know why throwing the bones like
he was if an a-list celebrity catches a
tray right right humble yeah
he's still a man of the kid's humble why
is it not humble when i do it oh yeah i
don't know
i get it though no for sure for sure
yeah they're just being jealous
oh that's all it is dude
when you go home do your fam bring up
your money
no they all make more money than me so
it's like it's finally like we can stop
paying for kevin uh or like well the big
thing now we just went on vacation and
like i'll pick up a check i'll be like
all right let and it's like
everybody'll be like oh my god it's like
i'll get [ __ ] what about too far i'm
throwing a hand
dude bought his mom diamonds
and then lied about the price
grand on these necklaces they were
emeralds i sent my mom some money for
her birthday she went oh my god you're
rich what you said there i just sent
there like some money like not even a
lot give me give me a number a 40 best
buy gift card
it was used 38 bucks she calls you
crying i never thought i'd see the day
what you said a couple hundred like
three hundred dollars nice but it was
like you know it seems very you know but
you send it in cash
what you give to your god son 300 bucks
keshap god you saw jesus christ
cash up in your mom money on her
birthday is the trashy as [ __ ]
here's some little walk around just put
an eggplant in the message
what drake does
that scumbag
i thought that was very quick no it's
very nice you get it immediately so much
so much of your cocktail bars
was there a note or anything no card
nice message in there like hey thank you
hey mom love you happy birthday
okay that's a good quick question catch
it that's good ain't got to get no card
those times are over that's all like
1990 [ __ ] no i agree i paid someone on
venmo for a wedding i like didn't give
him the card and i was just like i'm not
mad i'm not going to get a post office
and find a [ __ ] stamp an envelope oh
we were just
yeah yeah yeah just throw it at him here
you go your bums
filthy animals
don't call me no more take your money
but it does feel good though it feels
great it's the first time you know we're
also you know rewarding ourselves uh we
went to mineta tavern oh been there yeah
yeah oh i remember when y'all went i've
seen you all kind of you saw stumble out
of there yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] up
that was uh that because that was for us
we started in the village in new york in
the village together just all those
[ __ ] cold ass nights walking down
mcdougall and bleecker for shows for
like two people how many times i walked
by mineta tavern and like one day you
two smell these onion rings
one day i'll be in there it's [ __ ]
nice to finally be able to stand by the
door for a minute search smell your
hamburgers it's now it's nothing though
like you've been there it's like oh i've
been there that's fine i gotta reckon
last time i was in there i got
recognized where i was like can i take a
picture real quick i felt like [ __ ] i
felt so famous oh yeah that that happens
that happens like and when i'm in
brooklyn i thought he was diligent
probably
will come up so that feels good nice you
know what i mean especially when it's
like cutie
you turn into a dream [ __ ] maybe i got
cash app i look up
[Laughter]
start talking to the jamaican accent
pretend you're british
hello
that's all you can say
hello
you just keep repeating that no matter
what hello hello
all right so where have you where have
you been dabbling you said what's the
kind of you got a little cash uh what do
you order when you get to this sad
cocktail bar i'm getting i'm i'm getting
in the wine a little bit oh you know
what i like
martini espressos those are my espresso
martini martini yeah whatever it sounds
like an italian highway
what are they what are what is it
espresso
espresso martinis beans in it oh those
look at you those are my [ __ ] yeah
nice little spot are you having it to
kick the night off or are you having a
good night off kicking it off probably
keep drinking espresso martinis all
night i think the feds are looking for
you yeah it's like doing an eight ball
when you're waiting for a 3 30 a.m spot
[Laughter]
definitely start it off at seven be
hyped by three of you
we should start a business
i would love to see you trying to
navigate that glass for the first couple
of times
oh man it's good it's good eating down
in the village just feels good feels
nice you are so poor there for so many
years
percy's the delhi yeah walking dead at
black moons
no not my moons yeah we used to get oh
yeah yeah yeah i thought you meant now i
won't go in
[Laughter]
anywhere minetta lane if you keep
straight and walk down that like it's
all these little restaurants in the back
of
oh there's some spots around there yeah
you get over near 6th out you cross 6th
avenue over there really nice now when
you order a wine what are you
what are you into with wine i'll just
say first of all because i know this is
like wine's a very snooty snobby thing i
like eating it with like when i'm
looking shitty too like with a hoodie on
or something you go and get a nice wine
what do you water do you have a go-to or
do you know about what are you sticking
it to the man
i don't know i just feel like it makes
you i feel like a drug dealer a little
bit like a rapper i'm just sitting there
drinking wine i say when we go to nice
place late night
i say we're bitcoin people yeah we made
our money in bitcoin yeah i mean
t-bone's in like a [ __ ] rock star
t-shirt yeah it does look cool when
you're not dressed up but you're not
yeah because we're the outsiders yeah
yeah yeah yeah it feels good going into
a nice place everybody's like i think we
tell ourselves that i mean while i think
this guy got 11 together yeah everybody
yeah everybody knows these guys got like
a couple grand on a credit card uh it
feels good though sure
you try to i think we're so not used to
being in those situations that we lie to
ourselves yeah these [ __ ] they
don't know
i could be famous there's something cool
about like that whole adam sandler
effect where he like walks around and
just and one shorts and yeah and one
stretch but you know this guy is super
sure but the perception is that i'm
making a lot of money when i go home so
i still like to show up yeah i can just
be whatever yeah yeah well when you want
a hundred million dollars you can wear
basketball shorts it's weird i like wear
like i'm addicted to sweatpants foley i
know you only wear sweatpants oh man
that's about to change
start wearing them to funerals i don't
give a [ __ ] when was the last time you
did wear jeans
i don't even own a pair of jeans now
yeah
no i don't they're performing sweatpants
or joggers joggers when was the last
time i put on a pair of pants that had a
buckle on them a button i'm asking i'm
all drawstring now yeah oh me too all
drawstrings all drawstring
straight maternity wear straight seller
and i yelled it in what when i wore
sweats
who yelled at you liz
what the [ __ ] are you doing
i tried to wear like a a good top but
you got a shirt and tie on sweatpants i
tried to hide it up like what are you
talking about i don't know
she's my pants in a turtleneck
got a bow tie on it yeah oh god oh
you're drinking white you're drinking
reds what do you mean red only red your
red wine
red and do you know anything about them
you just go give me a cap
i don't know how to i'll say you don't
know how to pronounce it
so i'm like let me get a red wine and
then i'll go what would you suggest i'll
ask
oh that's a good idea yeah what are you
what do you think yeah yeah yeah and
then they'll tell me what they suggest
and i'll just pick a or b yeah i'll do
the second thing
i mean english isn't great for you let
alone french
does that third one come with a salad
hello i'll take uh eggs
oh god you stink i'll have that in the
shrimp cocktails
yeah but yeah i get real self-conscious
in those situations of like not knowing
how to pronounce things oh dude i'm not
knowing what's what you know i'm king
i'll google [ __ ]
oh yeah i'll do that too but sometimes
that takes forever
the waiter's looking at that one you're
ordering what the [ __ ]
i'll go i'll always go what would you
suggest
[Laughter]
ah yes my good man i'll have the
fetikini
i always go who would you suggest and
then if they don't know i'm like well
you just worked here
grow up
your first day idiot let's go that's
real
talk about acting like you haven't been
there before i'll have what you're
having what
yo man you eat this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what'd you all have for dinner in the
back would you be
now i don't [ __ ] with fish
that's the lord's food i'm looking at
other people's food hey what's that
is that good
that's good on it let me get a bite
hey my man let me get a green bean real
quick hey get a little piece
yo
brussels sprouts are good everywhere
brussels sprouts are good everywhere
yeah man
that's how you know somebody with no
money's got a little money when they
come across brussels sprouts
any [ __ ] men there
anywhere i've been and ordered brussels
sprouts they've been they're banging
amazing they're serious yeah i tried to
go home
they stink at home
everywhere i go i order brussels sprouts
and they're always so [ __ ] yeah
they're bad they've been killing it the
past couple of years yo i don't know
what they're so good oil salt bacon and
then stan puts honey on them yeah
so good honey and bacon
yeah man brussels sprouts are all right
every literally everywhere i go they
take them and they put them in what's
called a salamander it's like a broiler
and it [ __ ] just you know wait [ __ ]
on asparagus
asparagus is pretty good but brussels
sprouts and when i see brussels sprouts
on the menu i light up
i'm like get my veggies yeah give me the
beretta salad and um
oh man that's [ __ ] funny
you said he got into steak where how do
you get your steak or where are you
getting steak how do you get it done
well don't and during the pandemic i was
getting them in philly butcher going to
the butcher you were cooking yeah i was
kidding you were cooking from youtube
and then
from youtube
from watching youtube videos yeah i got
it mistakes
sound
[Laughter]
i got a subscription they come once a
month so i started making them during
the pandemic and then you i've been
non-stop ordering them like when i go
out not every time you're going out to
nice steaks yeah where have you been
going to
uh i went to manetta i went to it starts
with a g gallery y'all been there yeah
i've been there this is recently
well within the past couple months okay
like keith and [ __ ] and nice oh what
made you go together who'd you go to
what made you go to gallagher's because
i'll cook when i used to cook them at
home i go i want to see if how they are
yeah yeah yeah so
night and day isn't it
night and day yeah but oh i smothered
with butter when i was doing the searing
oh that's a fun time yeah yeah you feel
like you feel like a pro chef yeah yeah
with that little piece of tarragon in
there [ __ ] bathing time some um
garlic
some time um how do you order your steak
when you go out will you get media
medium rare medium medium medium rare i
like to see a medium what is it when you
see a little pink medium medium yeah or
medium well yeah i see that little pink
and plenty of ketchup
i don't know how they cook it you can't
see through all that ranch
you could be raw as far as i know i'm a
sauce guy too
oh man that's awesome yo how good are
the sauces at like nice i like good
places yeah the little zombie odds and
[ __ ] a one sauce is so trash
now that you when you go to other places
oh and you get like a homemade sauce oh
it's like it's always sweet yes it's
sweet at those nice places that one bite
you sop up as much as you can and i know
i'm a i'm a scooper when it comes to
sauce like i'm not a dipper
oh scoop you get it i have a spoon for
my steak
i get in there baby yeah huh wow that's
great yeah good you are eating good
brussels sprout money i like it that's a
good that that's a good level that's
where we're at
yeah yeah bang it out with brussels
sprouts oh that's so fun and waiter
recommended red wines yeah
i don't know how to order [ __ ] i always
ask what would you get
unless it's like
crazy what if they say like the most
expensive thing on the menu like i'll
get to you know this what i mean
it i've never had to
i've never been to wherever sword fell
you had a tongue i haven't had a
no we tomahawk
out we get the we'll get a porterhouse
for like courthouse are good for the
three of us and it comes for the table
and you just kind of
share it big big yeah
no way i'm sure we're full
we got them on one of those sticks with
the loop on it and they put dogs on
uh
mine on a rope bone and rib eye
nice oh rib eyes are great yes they are
top shelf delicious that's probably my
favorite steak yeah get that really
crisp and the outside
[ __ ] mmm it's good stuff a lot of fat
on there
love it i hated fat when i was a kid now
i l and i crave it
i made of it
i'm made of it it's like actually
let's talk about babble baby babble talk
about babble love babble if you're
trying to learn a new language maybe you
got a trip coming up you don't want to
sound like a bozo when you're in spain
or when you're in italy you don't want
to be over there down south or even down
south who knows what you want to do you
got to get on babel and figure it out
it's a fun addictive way to learn a
language yes uh babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons that you'll actually
use in the real world i know for me i
was trying to learn german for years i
was using all these different apps and
stuff like they teach you a bunch of
stupid [ __ ] you never use had me walking
around talking about my panties and
stuff yeah like that it's no good i mean
i don't need to know how to say the
sean's elysee i need to know the real
deal yeah you can cop a bag somewhere
babel's 15-minute lessons make it a
perfect way to learn new language on the
go other language other language apps
use a.i for the lessons planned but
babel uses lessons that were created by
over a hundred language experts not
forget about the matrix
right now when you purchase a three
month babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com use promo code garbage
that's babble
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code garbage babble
language for life do it all form baby
all forms you ever heard a helix pinhead
is that a helix comp that is a helix
company helix has stepped out of the
mattress game and they're getting into
the furniture biz and let me tell you
top quality easy to put together
great sit great not taking a lot of
great naps on this couch there's one
right there here in tutti's reggie
conquest is sitting on it right now yeah
it's a guy's a movie star got a movie
star sitting on your couch with his feet
on it
it's the easiest way to customize the
sofa using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you pick the fabric if you want
spill stain resistant scratch resistance
the color the legs a whole nine yards
it's super easy you get a love seat up
to an eight seat section or whatever you
want like you said they sent it to here
i set it up all together by myself easy
peasy forget about it good stuff uh they
give you 100 days aside if you want to
keep it that's more than three months
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free with a full refund but
you're gonna love it i'm telling you to
find the perfect sofa check out all form
dot com slash garbage and all former's
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at allform.com garbage one
more time all form.com garbage do it do
it uh but yeah it's been fun man
every time i'm not like nah of course
yeah but i definitely have my moments
where i go out and be like you know let
me get this you're starting to open up
to different things now yeah yeah it's
fine well it's funny to see like as you
know you realize how limited your world
view was the whole time you know what i
mean our life for so long was
dollar slices and you know yeah turkey
burger at the corner deli or whatever
you know what i mean i mean don't get me
wrong this stuff is still good oh yeah
okay
i still eat like [ __ ] well for sure dude
i went to the sixers game had two hot
dogs
relish must have filled them with
relish and mustard brought them from
home
hey can you mike can you nuke these for
me real quick oh no it's like but it is
night and day like i don't
nice seats at the sixers game
they're all right they're like middle
they weren't i was sitting there
thinking of that like man i can't wait
to be on that floor ah
y'all went recently right or no no no
okay okay no no um we went to the
we we you bought mets tickets and we
were like third row at the mets game oh
i've been late yeah i've been to a
baseball game and been right behind it
yeah
also like those are i mean they were
like
a hundred bucks yeah it wasn't they
[ __ ] mets were [ __ ] tanking yeah
the stadium was like nice
yankees i think okay okay see i can't i
went to the sixers game middle seats but
i kept looking at the
the courtside seats all right i'm gonna
get there one day as i ate my as you ate
here hot dog for my crab fries
shout out to the chicken pizza yeah yeah
eat my chicken
i'll be there you're still taking the
sunday cup home with you afterwards they
give you a big ass basket of chicken
pizza for us too yeah they're huge it's
a lot never been a fan of the crab
fries
cheese
oh
melted american cheese oh [ __ ] good
night yeah i can't i'm not a fan do you
realize well you're still kind of bit
but we would be so much you just say
yeah
i mean but we would be so much worse in
philly i say that all the time if i
didn't think if i didn't move to new
york i would be like if we were working
400 jobs huh we would feel like working
regular jobs no i'm saying like healthy
what like right now you get out you walk
around i'm sure like i'm starting to
yeah so
now
you could he he'll be dead if you're
looking at him like he schwarzenegger
dude all right my bad
no i actually i'd be 600 pounds in
philly if he did yeah he'd be dead yeah
yeah i would be i would probably be your
size for sure every time i see a
drinking guy in philly i'm like man that
wasn't me that could that would if i
stayed here that'd been me
[ __ ] soft pretzels will get you
yeah shout out to the philly soft
pretzels oh they will every time i'm in
wawa i'm like no there was times when i
was living in philly i was eating wawa
three times a day oh breakfast lunch and
dinner every time i go home now i'm
philly i eat that [ __ ] i know but you
know when you start eating a little
better you you do look down like
what the [ __ ] why am i focused you look
down at the other you look down at the
other people that are ordering yeah i
mean while you're getting your tuna
hoagie heated up
brussels sprouts last night [ __ ] i'm
gonna get a tuna hoagie with uh peanut
butter and uh just real gross yeah but
uh but yeah we would be through the roof
in philly yeah for sure fall through the
roof
ah good [ __ ] all right let's get to some
cubes here's some uh some garbage
questions guys your conquest here as you
know when you join the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on air it's
one of the perks to join in that patreon
over there uh
let's see this is from brian i know
foley's done this for sure ever shower
midday then put the same clothes back on
oh yeah
[Laughter]
underwear and everything
bundys undies is tough i if i if i
shower and i don't do anything that day
i will put on the same drawers the next
day
if i shower at night i'll sleep in them
and then maybe use them that next day
wait you you take a shower go to bed and
then change the draws in the morning no
i'm saying i'll put underwear on i sleep
in underwear okay and then i'll i'll get
out of the shower put on fresh underwear
at night
right
sleep in them
you're explaining strength
this guy's got two pair underwear
i don't know how to listen with my mouth
clothes
reggie's in scream
[Laughter]
trying to [ __ ]
they're trying to do pickups already the
waiter's telling you to special so would
you mind closing your mouth i'm like
this
what the [ __ ] is cuckoos
couscous is good
[Laughter]
you found that out huh what was that i
want to go about one question i wanted
to ask regarding what was the first have
you had like a uh
nationalities food that you haven't had
like ethiopian or a jet like middle east
or something you got into that you were
like oh i never even had sushi indian
food i remember the first time you had
sushi
yeah yeah like chicken fingers like this
but no no i called them japanese nuggets
which was very i was very he goes i'm
done with these japanese nuggets he
thought they were chicken nuggets yeah
why is this honey mustard spicy as [ __ ]
not really because i'm not a picky eater
i'll eat just about anything so no not
really because i was eating
different stuff when i didn't have a
little bit yeah yeah okay raw easter's
yeah i just got into them i got it my
dad made me get into them yeah you're
trying to [ __ ] it
they make it harder to rock those things
[Laughter]
no we went out and he just was like kind
of like stop being a [ __ ] and i was
like all right i don't [ __ ] with them no
no i do i i won't order them myself like
if they're there yeah fried oysters have
you taken him out to dinner yet yeah you
have yeah really that feels good wow
yeah that feels great yeah he's probably
falling over in his chair he'll every
time he leaves he'll cry
oh really yeah yeah that's awesome feels
good you still beat your ass yeah he was
just posting those pictures of him
there's one picture from like back in
the day he's dressed like
he's dressed like one of dmx's entourage
yeah all black shirt yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're like damn that dude is mean
yeah yeah
oh dude he used to tear me up but that's
my pop that's great dude poppy that's
awesome
so back to the drawers yeah i'll take a
shower at night so i get home from
whatever today take a shower night i'll
take a shower tonight 10 o'clock put on
a fresh pair of underwear
sleep in that okay wake up
not shower in the morning i might shower
and then that that underwear depending
on the surplus of underwear i have in
the drawer i might throw those on at
these that's a guarantee they still got
some legs left in them yeah if you only
sleep in them they're good plus you
nutted in them
[Laughter]
front of your boxes we all stained up
they're all crispy just turn it
backwards and keep it moving
inside out
fail i've never done that why i've never
turned my boxes inside out i have no
really i have for sure oh i thought you
meant to even turn them around no
inside out yeah [ __ ] in the back
he bent over him everyone's like yeah
richie who nutted on you
yeah [ __ ] you coming from here if i got
[ __ ] [ __ ] stains in the front of my boxes
i will change oh no we got a gentleman
over here
i will change that that's my campaign
promise to you when there's the american
people in my undies i will change in a
heartbeat
you you jerk off in a fresh parrot and
it stains up in the front i'm like all
right i'm done these are dirty
[Laughter]
i don't you don't i leave it in there
ugh it just disappears no it doesn't it
it really does not it's in there dude
i think i think my juices are made of
something different it just evaporates
ugh it's like science class it's
probably stuck in the back of your head
it turns into a sucked up in your body
it never really comes out my dick drags
it back into the cave
like the rancor monster
[Music]
oh god
yeah it does feel good i just brought a
fresh pack of draws it's great yeah i
gotta re-up that's funny man because
that that that's the stuff that's that's
awesome like you walk into a target i
mean a pack of underwear yeah i mean
fresh pack of socks yeah i just loaded
up too good fella with target real nice
bro i was just yo i got a good feel i
brought t-shirts yesterday the best
t-shirts in the game yes they're [ __ ]
they're killing it these are these are
good fellow joggers hey man y'all need
to be getting a check from them they are
[ __ ] killing it
fellas i don't i just got those fat guy
teas that they advertise online like on
instagram and
stuff graham got me in a chocolate i
brought one hat from instagram and
that's all i see i know yeah oh i got
your name it's changed so much i saw i
think now my in my info saved on it like
my credit card info yeah
it's like [ __ ] two clicks and i'm
like yeah it'll be at my door dude i'm
sometimes the [ __ ] don't show up though
i'll be up two in the morning just
clicking on ordering [ __ ] on amazon from
instagram that's so bad yeah it's the
best it's good it's it does feel good
but all i get is tooth pulling videos on
instagram ooh that and popping
is good that's all i get my algorithm is
uh
nails and
nails
yeah girls nails yeah is that why you
post all that stuff i just like it but
it's turning
wait what do you mean you like it i like
i like i like a fresh set really yeah i
love it it's it's an age thing i think
it's a age thing what about you are you
going to get manny's and petty's now or
not i'm a plan again i haven't got one
in a while but i'm gonna get one but i
just like it on women like it's
something i really notice you like when
their nails are done nice oh it's my
[ __ ]
nice nice look at when you're going man
that is that is real creepy yeah no i
don't you know what it's like it's
rooted sexually that's weird no it's not
is it
i don't know
i mean you're posting them on instagram
it's a little strange i like i post it
just just so people can so other women
can see it
they just tell me i got good taste so
i'd be like oh cool i like it man that's
a weird oh that's absolutely wait so
that's like your feet pictures yeah
that's yeah yeah and then he'll post
pictures
and then people go oh look at these
you're not saying that you like it when
you like it when a lady has her has her
nails done no i like that you're saying
you like looking at photo like it turns
you on to look at photos of nails i
wouldn't say it turn i see that's the
thing i don't get turned on i just like
have you ever turned it off to just
nails no no
i like it's a craft in it it's an art in
it and i just like the look this is a
pervert trying to make you kind of make
it sound like it's not creepy it's an
art it is an art it's a craft i love it
reggie has four pink fingernails up his
ass right now
no i think it's it's a very uh sexy
thing i like it okay all right i'll give
you that yeah i'll just post it and then
and then people will start sending me
their hands and that's what i'm saying
that's that that could be creepy creepy
people but i didn't ask you guys you're
not saying don't send me you're not
closing your dms that's how you're gonna
get hemped up some nine-year-old's gonna
say yeah just fix your hands you're
gonna be up at six that hand looked
thirty
[Laughter]
what nine-year-old is harry knuckles
your honor
look at her hand
people think i got a business though
cause i say business is booming
it's so funny i'll be on instagram just
playing
just watching i know you're one of my
favorite followers you'll do things that
are so
you'll do like recurring things that are
so
small and stupid but like it's so stupid
and you like comment on it days like
it's just so funny yeah it's it's stupid
i really just go in there to play i try
to use it for what it's for i haven't
found my like you guys have found your
thing that you use it for i have no
reason to have fishing for kink picks
send me a kneecap will you i have no
reason to be on social media but i i'm
still on it for some reason
oh i love it i want to find something
though but whatever elbows i post my
friend [ __ ] i think i i really believe
in posting and supporting yeah just
posting people [ __ ] they doing dope [ __ ]
people are p i hate when people ask me
though i don't like that [ __ ]
hey can you post just like [ __ ] no b do
you think i just post anything
let me see your nails send it to the
booker will you
oh that's great all right uh this one's
from aaron um ever been to a family
reunion and thought one of your distance
cut your distant cousins was
good-looking absolutely oh my god yeah
you guys do family reunions he's weird
for not
no i think he did oh okay uh i haven't
done a favor what's a distant cousin
theoretically not on the side of the
room
not immediate not like your mom's
sister's daughter what about a sex a
second and third cousin that to me would
be distant
well if what if it's your first cousin
but you see her once a year
got nice fingernails that's distant too
though no no that's not genetics not in
the blood genetically that's close i
don't believe in that
what are you talking about
the vaccine too
have you ever been to
england a bunch of trolls walking around
over there do you ever see the british
office come on
okay yeah so that's this i don't think
there's nothing wrong with that
oh no yeah i can't do it that's what i
memorized i mean as a little kid you
can't control that so here we go
[Laughter]
what are we getting into big man because
i'm here for i'm just saying as a little
kid if you have an older cousin
and she's attracted what if she's the
same age though because little kids you
never had a kissing cousin when you were
younger
i mean me neither i was just asking
got that
um well yeah try to enjoy my
thanksgiving
nobody's saying a word
uh i think yeah there was a little
doctor going around a little household
doctor [ __ ] like that sure
you know i got a cousin with a fat ass
[Laughter]
his name's ed
it's a squat machine
i haven't been to a family union though
in a while
have you do them growing up now we we do
them now we did them i would always miss
them the last one you went to was
probably about five years ago we do it
on the beach in wildwood real trashy
[ __ ] all right i think i remember that
we set up big tents in the back
everybody's all [ __ ] up smoking
ends up with like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know
it's real irish catholic trash
yeah somebody somebody's getting pushed
or shoved or held back at some point
does your family do the shirts yeah we
do the shirts the sullivan whatever
family are you it's a tree i thought you
were asking reggie that no we definitely
i've definitely i've only been in like
two when i was a kid and then probably
like 16 and we did the shirts
yeah conquest family reunion there was a
kid in my high school uh their last name
was lo sean lowe he was you great
younger than me but have like a you know
like a bunch of older brothers and [ __ ]
like that and cousins in the school and
they they always had their uh low family
reunion shirts
that
where other people like other people
started wearing them
because there were so many others
because it feels like a thing yeah
because everybody everybody thought it
was a cool t-shirt i think that's how
stuff ends up now like that's how
everything every people just wear
t-shirts if anything i have mad t-shirts
of literally anything on it yeah like
just what i'm sayings and i try to buy
just random t-shirts what did you post
about um
uh
white people doing one thing and black
people doing the other with funerals
white people oh that uh why don't white
people
do the t-shirts with the with the r.i.p
on themselves yeah yeah yeah um some of
that stuff is just random [ __ ] i'd be
sitting on the toilet just going off
on the toilet because they don't
they don't they're white celebrities if
they do they grew up in a rough
neighborhood yeah i've never seen them
from the hamptons yeah rest in peace
i've never seen a white celebrity in the
clouds that's what it was
[Laughter]
never like you know when like kobe died
and nipsy hustle they're all in this
cloud and they walk into the they're all
walking to heaven yeah yeah you i've
never seen a white celebrity
in class as a black celebrity you know
you've made it when you end up in the
cloud yeah yeah but i've never and then
people were like oh because they're
white and evil and i was like
betty betty white we loved her we loved
the show mr rogers and people was quiet
[Music]
um
and i i think we were talking i was
thinker over here
betty white huh mr ross ah come on paul
and paul walker come on shout out to
paul walker there's three white people
that come to the top of your head yeah
paul walked that's a weird squad betty
white mr rogers
fascinating i only said those three
because people kept saying oh it's
because they're all evil and then i then
i said those three can people stop
saying because white people are all evil
and i'm like i named those three to drop
it all already shut up it shows them
walking into hell
stepping on a baby
away by betty white being drunk away by
two demons
kim want to talk to you about ladder
ladder all right you're a young kid but
you're not going to be for long you got
to look into term life insurance
you want to make sure you take care of
your family saw a commercial for ladder
on the old tv the other day yeah they
know what they're doing they're moving
and shaking
term life insurance get on board with
them everything's 100 digital no doctors
no needles no paperwork when you apply
for three million in coverage or less
three million just need a couple of
minutes a phone laptop to apply ladder
smart algorithms smart algorithms work
in real time so you get aerosmith to
play at your funeral so you'll find out
if you're instantly approved uh if you
want to if you prefer to talk to a
person you can do that and the team of
licensed agents does not work on
commissions so they're gonna help you
not upsell you yeah you know what i mean
whatever try to get you on the undercoat
so go to ladderlife.com garbage today to
see if you're instantly approved that's
ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life dot com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage manscaped baby
best in the bez those man's guess who's
back back in town manscape coming around
tony's yeah wanting to want a second
peek at the boys must be moving some
lawn mowers over here
i like to see it gang
manscape doesn't just make the lawnmower
4.0 the amazing [ __ ] ball trimmer
nope they also have a nice little line
of products all-in-one hygiene skin hair
bundle is designed to upgrade the
everyday man shower routine from head to
toe look at that who don't need that who
doesn't need that forget it you're
probably using a bar on your skin like a
dirt bag you got to get on the manscape
tip yeah uh once you hop out of the
shower protect yourself from body odor
by applying the manscaped aluminum free
deodorant they also got uh the two in
one shampoo conditioner that cleans and
nourishes in one step non-greasy formula
the whole nine yards also while you're
in the shower you lather the clone
infused ultra premium body wash with
aloe vera and sea salt to keep your skin
looking feeling clean moisturize all
goddamn day cologne infused yeah
obviously they got the lawnmower 4.0
electric trimmer to clean anyway
unwanted body hair do my mustache i'll
do anything
ceramic tip powerful motor but it's
quiet it's water resistant you get a
little light on there so you don't cut
your nuts off yeah
good stuff
god damn it i cut my nuts off again then
they fought on the drain you got to get
a plumber in there
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code garbage at manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with code garbage
at manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean your and clean with your new
manscape shower routine do it yeah we
love them i was saying that uh
we do the sometimes the windshield in
the back of the car what's that well
we'll have like
you know
so and so 2000 whatever to whatever oh
oh like the me the memorial oh yeah okay
see that i'm like an escalator steve
on the rear on the on the what's what
the [ __ ] it called the rear windshield
yeah the rear windshield are you saying
like family members or with the dates no
with the dates i like to have somebody
to pass like 19.
tony oh that's so lazy
with the wings and [ __ ] like that oh
okay oh i know what you're talking about
now no no i see black people in the
clouds the gates yeah walking in looking
back i was like damn
people get artsy when black people die
crazy
that was also i throw on a horse
[Laughter]
one meme said it was a meme he said
don't put me in the clouds put me put a
po put a bowl of wings behind
put me in the blue cheese yeah it's so
funny that [ __ ] oh my god
i wouldn't want to be in the clouds
either
i don't even i definitely don't want an
open casket and i don't want i don't i
don't want the the
the dead guy picture either this dead
guy pictures it it's going to be weird
if you die immediately after this yeah
you died you guys do everything i didn't
want
[Laughter]
start printing the t-shirts
oh god paint his fat ass in the clouds
oh
every time i start thinking about death
i immediately go no no no no
bunny rabbits bunny rabbits
fingernails
immediately i try to work on my thinking
and positive thinking and immediately go
the other way
i don't even like talking about holy
[ __ ] that's so [ __ ] funny
funny rabbits
fingernails fingernails fingernails
love them
uh that was we were talking about it
before our friend chris cotton that was
my first uh
black funeral that i attended
and that's when i realized we do
funerals completely different oh yeah i
mean that was there was an intermission
there was there was acts going on there
was a thing there was an open mic the
band was [ __ ] pop shot yeah there was
food being served it was everything was
yeah out of food yeah it was all in one
unit rather than ours would like you'd
go to you go to the viewing of the the
mass and then to like
lunch in afterwards yeah it was like an
all-inclusive party
i got a wristband when i walked in it
was like being out of sandals
i went to a metal detector
i don't know where they got that water
slide from
there
no i'm saying it was more of a i
remember walking out like oh [ __ ] that
was i felt good
well you go to the we go to the viewing
and then to the cemetery normally that's
how it
it but and then somewhere else yeah but
everybody i was so relaxed when chris
body wasn't in there i was so nervous
walking in kept leaning and i hope it's
like he was standing in the back and
then i see anyone up there like honestly
man
pass me a plate reggie relax it's just
macaroni salad
if they lift up that chafing dish i
swear to god
if he's next to the cocktail weenies i'm
out of here
yeah it was fantastic oh that was so
[ __ ] funny oh man
that was the first time we all seen each
other cry too
yeah yeah
no oh that's the first time we all cried
together i've seen
everybody
we've all cried individually outside of
the lantern or something or like on a
subway or oh yeah you all lead all the
first movies we all got the west fourth
street
but maybe not together or maybe not we
saw but each one of us has definitely
cried
at the west fourth street station at
like three in the morning waiting on a
train that's never coming
he's just looking down like oh what am i
doing
maybe if i get a check spot at state of
new york some old man in the corner that
trains never come out this station's
been closed for you you should move home
[ __ ] up old man move home and get fatter
i will you know what that just this is
this is a fat thing you're gonna you're
gonna get on me for this but you know
what i miss but hitting the [ __ ]
candy shop down at the subway when those
things are open oh they're a little hot
little newsstands oh they're still open
they're they're back open yeah it's like
august and you're sweating your balls
off and you're looking for a cold water
and they're all hot oh dude they heat
them up on you all the candy's dusty you
know what i can tolerate the train now
but when it gets hot i probably i think
that's what i'm gonna be done for a
while yeah i got my bike i'm ready
though i can't wait till it get nice
there you go yeah i got my bike i'm
bringing shot hey uh we riding baby yeah
i can't you have a nice bike yeah i love
that [ __ ] bike i look at it every day
wishing i can ride it
who's shot day the singer no the bike
that's the name is that where you call
her yeah i'm gonna get a helmet this
year too i'm tired of people hitting me
up look you need a helmet every time i
post
what kind of bike
i don't know i got off instagram
literally it's called it's pink there's
tassels on it it's nice
it's called soleil bicycles
and they still advertise me solely
bicycle
it's a good bike though oh man i don't
know that doesn't sound sturdy at all
it's a good bite
it sounds like a bad energy it's all
black right it's all black all murdered
out
like it's it's a good looking bike baby
i can't wait till that they get stolen
i've thought of that you're gonna
probably 100 if i got stolen you would
cry i would cry how much was it
it's 400
it's not bad yeah and i bought it last
summer what's that what's a real
expensive bike toby like a real
expensive speed oh you could get a bike
for 15 grand all right yeah that's
[ __ ]
you ask me the price i tell you to use
drop 1500
this [ __ ] just prices right the
[ __ ] out of me
yeah one dollar
that was awesome oh now you're getting
like 25 grand yeah that bike sucks
an instagram bike that does sound a
little tough hey the lady has been
[ __ ] with this amazon market whatever
it is their grocery store it's whole
foods essentially it shows up a couple
hours after you order it wait you do
that you do she start she just started
doing a couple weeks ago and she got uh
new england clam chowder which
it sat there for two days i was like are
you out of your [ __ ] mind you just
got new england clam chowder from
[ __ ] amazon and then she had a bowl
for lunch and she gave me a taste
[ __ ] top shelf i know what they're
doing i think the norms of that stuff is
changing well oh yeah we'll be ordering
pizzas off instagram soon no way i have
my way
if i run the world
[Laughter]
i haven't typed into the the the grocery
store
people do that though yeah it's nice i
dude i never did
but what about fruit and [ __ ] i feel
like if i was doing that i would not
give a [ __ ] about people i was just like
oh you need this here oh god oh the
people doing it don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll be like oh would
you want this but this is close enough
here you go
how do you how do you uh
yeah yeah well they've gotten better
because they're amazing
the inventory now they have like they
used to be like hey this is what we have
this is what we sell but then if they
were out of it it wasn't updated now
like the inventory is updated constantly
so there's like a better okay okay you
can get when it's out of something it's
you know they let you know that they're
out it feels really good like dude i
never did and i don't have a [ __ ]
bank account
i i got i got a bank account when we
were we were up here yeah you know what
i mean like that's that's how recently
i've had a bank account doing that kind
of stuff feels real nice it does feel
good yeah even just ordering online
ordering something online and not
everything not checking the price just
ordering just like take a little peek
every now and then
if you go crazy you go all right let me
slow it down
how often do you check your bank account
today on your app not not not like i
used to do it every day now just be like
i know how much is in my account and i
go all right i look at like every 15
minutes really yeah just in case
anything's gonna leave or just disappear
or whatever just paranoia oh yeah yeah i
mean i still got some tech stuff i need
to work on
so yeah
but no i don't check it every day that's
nerve-wracking
oh yeah yeah i check it maybe once a
week just to make sure i'm not
overdrawing yeah if i'm uber and crazy i
might check it
like yeah taking a couple oobies are you
oh
you doing uber xl uber black no no no
straight up straight up uber i don't
post none of that [ __ ] though i just i
don't want people the more you posted
what you doing people think you're doing
you know what i mean yeah no yeah of
course you don't want people all up in
your biz yeah yeah yeah that uber xl
sometimes when that shows up and it's
got like the handicapped thing in the
front oh yeah it's like one of the vans
that like has a crane on it it's a bay
yeah there's a bunch of hot chicks out
front of the club i haven't done an uber
two dogs in the back i just do regular
uber but man we do them on the road i
sent you a picture of one when we landed
in atlanta we were talking about i had
it ready you had it it was ready for you
no no no no no no no no we don't have
that [ __ ] it's cool that's it yeah i
mean that's that's [ __ ] cash yeah
that [ __ ] no we get the excels on the
road and it you do feel
you feel like presidential or you feel
rich when you get in you're like have
you ever have you ever had that i'm
surprised you haven't had that one of
the shoots or something like that when
you fly
yeah down just dope mr conquest that
[ __ ] will say uh sometimes i have my
[ __ ] government like
[ __ ] my name is reggie i keep forgetting
your name yeah yeah yeah so it is his
real name shelly sure
but
it's james reginald
wait your name is james too no kevin
james okay like the guy but no they that
is cool the whole you get off the air
you get off the thing and the guy is
holding that [ __ ] it's awesome
i got like three videos in my phone that
i haven't posted you let them carry your
bags i get them all that [ __ ] i'll stay
right
it's [ __ ] up the instinct is to treat
them like [ __ ]
i'm the first one to drop it next time
i've never i've never had it
hey buddy you wanna come over here and
get this from me hey pick this up while
i record you
the first time that happened i
definitely did that just out of like
oh [ __ ] let me get this you know i don't
do it now you're driving
take a load off huh what do you want to
listen to i'm stepping in the car extra
looking up hey
you get it all right i'm looking around
have you had they sent a proper limo for
you yet or just like to take a limo just
like the town car but that's still cool
cause you come outside the
motherfucker's waiting with the door
open they're like cleaning it and [ __ ]
wiping it down yeah it makes you feel
nice i get why i asked you man
you gotta tell me if you're a cop i
totally understand how some actors are
just [ __ ] because they they pampered
the [ __ ] out oh god it's so easy to turn
zero touches how do you uh you've
obviously been on a lot of shoots and we
don't get a lot of actors you know
people that do a lot of acting work in
here uh so much
how do you act cause you are 100 reggie
all the time you can't not be reggie
yeah how do you act
on like what are you like trailers what
do you like at the crafts table that's
what i want to know are you doing you
you're doing yours you had the crab
somebody on set told me you got
tupperware because i imagine by the end
of the day you got a full belly of
clipboards but i i've cooled out but
they said one time somebody's like one
of the production systems was like you
eat like nobody's watching
yeah
yeah they ain't you're fired [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know betty white you [ __ ]
but no i try to treat everybody the same
every but they're so nice it's almost
like annoying a little bit like it'd be
like i'll get you coffee don't leave no
no no i can get i can get it but then i
had to get used to that yeah
at some point like yeah i'll take a half
you know i'll take an espresso martini
or whatever it is
i i i i uh i beat y'all like i'll like
hang out and then i'll be like all right
let me not hang out with everybody
because then when the clock's over these
[ __ ] people are lunatics
yeah when they're on the clock yeah
you'd be like uh all right let me go
back to my room
hey reggie you want to come over
i don't know how to i got to learn how
to be by myself
like i don't like being by myself like
going on the road like i'm sure you guys
have fun uh we pal around a good time
dude i see that and i go [ __ ] like i
don't like you taking time out
everywhere just for the [ __ ] hangs
yeah it's always a comedy it's only been
it's only been a few months but if i was
by myself i would definitely be dead by
now yeah it's like being by yourself is
so when i am on a set or something like
that i just try to
be cool and see
see if somebody invite me to a hang
later because i [ __ ] what are you
doing later yeah i'm that guy like hey
what everybody what y'all doing you guys
all hanging out in someone's room or
what's going on
like i don't like i don't want to go
home so like i'm always on new york time
and ready to hang and uh actually reggie
i'm having dinner with john lithgow and
leonardo
all right where are we going
they got good they got good red wine
they got a special martini i'll have one
japanese nuggets there i'm in
i must've i didn't muscle but
oh [ __ ] can i say this yeah of course he
was that he came to a show in brooklyn
at me and uh the mesh run
i was going to the cellar and he said he
was going so i just straight asked him
like hey i'm going that way can we can i
go and i was just in the front of his
uber just quiet just right
why'd he get in the back seat with him
he did no he was in the back with like
one of his assistants or whatever and
they were just talking i was just up
there like
we're going to wait were you was there a
plastic shield that you were no okay
i was just sitting up front like all
right yeah can we roll through the
drive-through with the king real quick
but you know he was cool he don't
remember me but i definitely you know
muscled my way in that uber that's a
classic that's right
yeah yeah
hey you going that way yeah if you're
going
to stop by my house real quick you're
going that way why not rob me oh you
don't want to rob me you're a mean piece
of [ __ ]
cause there's certain situations that
have happened you're insane i don't run
to like social media like it was when i
was looking for an apartment this guy
was legit being racist to me like he was
how'd you get in the building he kept
questioning me how'd you get the the
realtor yes he was being pregnant you
say hi i'm reggie i'm here to see the
apartment yes how'd you get in here
later i thought like damn i could have
[ __ ]
posted it again
but i was so ready to go and angry that
that didn't even come to mind so
something like that
when he said how did you get we were
just in an apartment
we were just in an apartment cussing
each other out wait really
wait nah
go to see in the park you're making
appointments go to see an apartment lady
i'm on the first floor did you make an
appointment with you yes okay so the
lady lets me with this guy with this guy
this is in [ __ ] crown height
somewhere this lady lets me in i'm
standing in the hall he sucks he's like
yeah where you at he's outside
and i'm and he he already has an
attitude i can tell he's like yeah how'd
you get in the building and i'm like
yeah lady look man you got to let me in
let me know if you're coming into the
building he started
and i'm like yeah the lady let me in so
we're in and then he said it again so
i'm like dude the lady let me in and he
was like look man i'm not going to be
able to your tone i'm like man [ __ ] you
i start i snapped down on him and he's
like he's like [ __ ] we we're standing
in the apartment
i'm not gonna get approved for this lisa
yeah i i didn't give a [ __ ] at that
point i think the board members are
gonna sign off now on this we're
standing up you beat his ass now show me
the bedrooms [ __ ]
you had a two bed right i'm staying in
an apartment with this dude and he's an
empty apartment empty apartment dude i
literally just walk in like we walk into
the kitchen space and we stand there
like this and he like [ __ ] you i'm like
[ __ ] this and jenna we're going back and
forth and i'm lee i just leave like [ __ ]
you no no like it was it was bad was he
a big dude he wasn't that big you were
taking him i could have took him yeah
but it was what was he
oh some [ __ ] white guy but he was he
had a [ __ ] attitude when he came in
like he must have been having a bad day
and it just
showed up you know to me so you walk
into the hallway
of this building yeah he says how'd you
get in there did you get in here then
you guys it wasn't the first time would
you guys close the door like a couple
like when you got it you gotta shut the
point till we get into the apartment god
damn it he he stood near the door as i
walk in and the third
hey man you got to let me know i can't
like that the third thing was what got
me i'm like dude what does that got to
do with anything
you're a
customer but later on i thought about it
he just didn't want me in that building
he didn't want me he didn't want to give
that apartment to me yeah but it's crown
heights i mean it's
it was a very like nice jewish yeah yeah
there's there are the two sides of crown
heights which is race reports yeah so i
thought about it later like oh that was
just his way and he it worked
it worked he didn't want me in the
building yeah and i'm not in the
building yeah i'm not in the building he
came in he jumps out of the closet or
you're looking at the compartment ah
he just didn't want me in but that was
his way of i'm sure he does that and
that was his way of sure saying no just
being like yeah he got unruly he you
know he didn't listen to myself yes i'm
like i left i'm like that was a good
plan
it works
email him love the place
he's racist ain't dumb
have you checked my references i'm
pretty goddamn good at it yeah that's
all i left like i thought about it the
later like oh that was pretty good it's
pretty i respect the move my man
because i [ __ ] snapped out on this
dude all right yeah i would have freaked
out but i do got to get better at
pulling out my phone and recording but
with my luck
somebody look in the camera and go [ __ ]
and i'm like all right well
i can't post that i'll get cancelled
this is too harsh for my brand
wait you didn't see the phone i'm
filming here
press record buddy
he's like so
all right well
you won this one
not showing his footage
not posting my elves
hey look at this guy look at the camera
call me inward look at this guy
completely owning me
by [ __ ]
brave man stands up to racist realtor
immediately gets owned
right great realtor
with my luck that would happen yeah the
great realtor prevents unruly unruly
applicant oh that wasn't useful
good lord
good lord you do see those videos where
people just double the [ __ ] down yeah
some lady losing it in the [ __ ]
walgreens yeah i you know what i kind of
i kind of enjoyed it i love videos
throwing like shopping carts i don't
give a [ __ ] you're filming me
jesus i respect it
i think he's crazy
he's got like cereal and chips in your
car they said it were like three times
and people were like look at him they
said it again
again also they always the person
recording obviously these people are
great like they always get to the point
we're like oh i got them and they're
like oh no they're just crazy yeah it's
like all right is he gonna put the phone
down and beat some ass yeah where are
you gonna get a knuckle up here now
she set up the camera we're playing
street rules get a cat get a [ __ ]
tripod and start whooping
inside my tripod you'd be real sorry
right now [ __ ]
you're like you don't have my selfie
stick on me
i [ __ ] you up [ __ ] you and your tripod
one of those videos i'm just going to
hey man hold this and then you just
this is so stupid there's one every once
in a while when they [ __ ] they [ __ ]
them up
the craziest thing is
you gotta you don't respect it but just
the balls or craziness of the person is
they've they've already said it
and then they press record and they go
this person just called me the n-word
he won't say it again and then they said
it again they look dead in the camera
[ __ ] i'm going to get a promotion for
this what are you talking about yeah
they could have got away
they'd be right in a place where they
would say it and you go first i'll be
watching like why are you there
what do you mean what are you doing in a
florida target lady yeah that's what you
get why are you why are you in this
florida why why are you there
he had no business beating that panera
bread anyway
i was doing i was doing no bread anyway
i should have been here i should be
watching my weight i'm gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here if that ever happens i
would never post it
[Laughter]
my head hurts we gotta wrap it up oh
buddy
always we love you oh man i always
laughed at my [ __ ] head hurts dude
proud of you happy to see you you guys
proud of you guys here we are humble
beginning love you doing okay
you guys are good love you buddy are you
really getting steaks after this if you
want to yeah yeah
we got to do another episode but you can
you guys who
we're doing with us you're going to hang
if you want okay
all right
hey he's hanging later
no he's he's regretting saying yes to
dinner now he's got to wait an hour
i know reggie hey i was going to bond
chicken
i'll see you guys this weekend
wait can i be on a second episode or no
sure of course you edit me out
just blur them
yeah it's going on the patreon okay
[Laughter]
oh my god that [ __ ] is killing
dude funny special in the longest time
i've seen that's the comedy i grew up on
just quick random fast we were literally
just talking about this with colin
terrell upstairs we were talking about
the laugh house i've only seen the first
15 minutes of it just because i he's
[ __ ] up let's see if we save that we
can talk about it on the page
good stuff kippy what do you got for him
uh did you plug plug anything so what do
you got shows anything coming up i'll be
at the the seller and uh stan uh every
weekend check out his uh fingernail man
you're really clammed up you're in
movies we just talked to you we just
talked about how good you're doing
i need media training um but yeah uh
check out go follow them on instagram
follow me on twitter oh you're not on
twitter no i'm not on twitter instagram
red's conquest uh that damn michael
chase season two is coming they got uh
some other fun stuff is coming so yeah
go check him out support [ __ ] reggie
he's one of our oldest pals uh guys
check us out on the [ __ ] road we're
all over the place we still got uh let's
go cali we got cali did we just
announced it
so we announced the tickets like [ __ ]
um less than a month before the shows so
get those [ __ ] tickets some of them
are already [ __ ] halfway sold out i'm
telling you that now so l.a la jolla san
fran we also got pittsburgh buffalo
detroit
phoenix salt lake city chicago rosemont
more more cities coming get those
[ __ ] tickets rosemont show the [ __ ]
up yeah
old town is going to sell old towns
almost sold out so [ __ ] buy your
tickets kids are moving some tickies
around here
peace peace